well usually you get a lot of these
around the holidays
and especially in mall parking lots and
people take
leaving packages in their cars and
things of that nature and if you leave
things in your car including
neighborhoods
generally speaking we'll start with
neighborhoods
um thieves don't break the windows and
you know it goes the
full gamut from juveniles to adults uh
usually um uh my experience is their
check they check the car doors to see if
they're unlocked and then they rifle the
car
rifle for change or things of that
nature if you leave something and they
have a flashlight
and it looks an opportunity for them
they
they will break the windows usually they
just look for open windows
i see that a lot on
next door which is uh
the next door neighborhood alert by ring
the ring app uses that
and then the our neighborhood alert is
one and then next door app
which next door um applies like
uh um to different communities like
north las vegas probably has a next door
app
probably have several of them in their
community which is a
uh you know a much wider app
than the neighborhood alert by ring but
i see a lot of people posting things
on there and if you do have that
opportunity and you are using cameras
and such
then uh post pictures of those people i
see a lot of times
these people post a picture of thieves
on the app to try to identify them but
definitely give them to the police to
try to identify them
but don't leave things in your car that
lock your car
and don't leave things in there that
create an opportunity as i said
generally they won't break the windows
if they don't see anything and they just
check the doors
and you have kids and adults walking
through neighborhoods
checking doors on cars and driveways and
on the street
uh looking for opportunities uh and uh
you know it's it's it's don't don't give
them that opportunity and then
with the the amount of cameras that we
see now that people have
in front doorbell apps not just ring
share those with the police and share
them with your neighbors
you know post have flood lights some
people have flood lights that turn on
when there's motion and some people have
flood lights that are on all times
in their driveway and such so and the
same applies to
commercial parking lots any parking lot
most of the time thieves will just try
the door to see if it's unlocked
and then move on um if they see
something in the car depending
they see something in the car they may
uh try to break in they may try to dr
uh during the holidays we'll see that in
um
small shopping uh areas where they
actually drill the car the whole
drill the holes around the lock and able
to break in
um so um and that's usually
a conversation left for the holidays uh
but if you're carrying packages to your
car
or if you leave packages in your car
thieves are walking and looking and
uh you know mall security or in parking
lots is usually um
pretty vibrant with uh cars with visible
security
and such but um you know it's just
whatever opportunity you leave for
thieves
they will take that opportunity you know
i think a big misconception is a lot of
people think if you have tinted windows
that that i mean maybe that helps but i
mean i've heard of a lot of situations
where people still have their car
burglarized even if their windows are
completely black
um another topic i want to bring up is
even if you do have a garage and you
leave your car in the garage it's
important to lock
your car when in the in the garage
correct
yeah depending on on the most garage
openers the modern ones have a rotating
combo
in in the old days uh you could uh
you know it was a um a one two or a plus
minus on your key code
and thieves would drive through the
neighborhood clicking a button and if
they saw
a i've been the victim of that if they
saw a
door that would open up they'd close it
and then they'd come back later
uh maybe two o'clock in the morning
knowing they could open the garage
and uh um and take whatever
so uh modern uh garage doors
have a rotating locking system in other
words it's the
the lock is the number is always
changing
now they still try that but they're
they're the the success of that
is much more frequent uh than how it
used to be but yes
i would recommend lock your doors in in
your garage
absolutely is there anything that you
would say
that people may might not think about
like oh it's okay to leave it like
obviously you don't want to leave your
wallet you don't want to leave your
purse
a laptop but as are there any things in
particular that you're like you know
what you also don't want to leave this
and i know you wouldn't think
that it would be an issue but it is uh
well i'll give you an example i know a
person who left a spare key in his glove
compartment and uh uh for uh the car
wash for valet parking
and things of that nature so he didn't
have to leave his key ring and he forgot
to lock his
uh door one night his car door and
someone got into his car found the key
and stole his truck
so that would be that would be a good
example they didn't see they just it
just happened to be the door they didn't
break the window
they just opened the door and there was
as a rifling through they find the
ignition key and uh
wow now i can make a kick quick getaway
with his truck and took the truck
so um there's the diff yeah
don't leave your wallet in the car
certainly don't leave firearms in the
car
uh because you think it's impregnable
because
you've locked the door occasionally
thieves will break the window
but it's not a usual occurrence it's
usually just checking the door to see if
it's unlocked
another thing i think is the
registration because the registration
has
your information on it as far as where
you live and everything like that
so finding that registration then maybe
putting it back
and then kind of surveillance like
watching
say you they know your routine they
watch your car they know you're at work
then they go to your house and try to
burglarize your house that's another
theory
you don't see much of that um that's a
theory
um uh there used to be a thing where
um if you leave your house keys not
not impossible that you leave your house
key um
on your key ring when you go to a valley
parking and
uh somebody might make a copy of your
key with just an imprint pad
possible uh and stealing your
registration info
so they can go uh burglarize your house
possibly
but most burglaries that are in a
residential neighborhood are
somebody knocks on the front door goes
around back throws a brick through the
uh
back window and gets in and out as soon
as they can
so um unless they were specifically
wanting to target you that's a
possibility
if they're targeting you is to get that
information off of registration
have you seen in just recent years more
car thefts having to do in in
neighborhoods or more so
in you know public places
uh you know i haven't seen the
statistics on that
but i believe more car thefts take place
in parking lots than they do in
neighborhoods but
it's once again it still it happens in
both places
i guess the answer that would be yes
okay is there anything else that you
would want to add that i maybe didn't
ask
um no just a piece practical safety um
that type of thing if you get video give
it to the police
put it on your app uh whichever one
you're on post a picture of somebody
if they're roaming the neighborhood you
see them walk by
i've seen them on i have both uh the
neighborhood alert and the next door app
and people post pictures
of suspicious people especially if
they're you know and when i say
suspicious trying car doors or have
flashlights looking in cars
post pictures uh nine times out of ten
it's probably gonna be somebody in your
neighborhood